JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Hello.
And welcome to DEV.BYTES.
My name is Jan-Felix Schmakeit,
and I'm from the
Android Developer
Relations team.
In this episode, we are looking
at the Hierarchy
Viewer and how you can use
that tool to fix overdraw
issues in your application.
So let's have a look at our
demo application here.
So this looks a bit like
an RSS reader.
We're calling it the Bacon
Reader application.
So you can select articles
here on the side.
And you can read some text
here in this frame here.
This is a quite standard
Android layout.
Here we have a fragment here
for the list on the side.
And we have one fragment here on
the right-hand side for the
main content.
So let's look at Hierarchy
Viewer.
And I will show you how
this application--
what the application looks
like in Hierarchy Viewer.
So the Hierarchy Viewer
application is part of the
Android device monitor.
You can simply open it up by
clicking on the Hierarchy
Viewer button up here.
So once you've loaded in your
application, you've selected
your activity.
You get this tree up here.
And this tree basically shows
you what you have used in your
application actually
looks like.
So in this case here, you can
see we have a linear layout.
And this is where our entire
application lives.
So we can drill down
a bit further.
So you can see here,
we have a ListView.
And this is coming from the
fragment that you have on the
left-hand side.
You can see here, this
is what we have.
In this list, because this is
what's [? drawn ?] inside it.
And you also notice that we have
these colored dots here.
And these dots indicate how
quickly each of these views
was drawn So green means
it was very fast.
Yellow means it was faster
than 50% of the views.
And the red means it's one
of the slowest views
in your view hierarchy.
So this is actually quite a nice
tool that allows you to
drill down and see what your
application actually looks
like when you run it, and in
particular when you use some
more complicated layouts.
This really helps you
troubleshoot some of the
layout issues.
So if you want to use the
Hierarchy Viewer in your own
application, you have to include
the ViewServer class
in your application.
You can get it from this website
down here that's on
the screen.
And I'll show you what
that looks like.
So you basically just drop
it into your application.
In this case, here in
Android studio.
And then you have add a few
calls inside your activity
life cycle in the activity
you want to
look at in more detail.
So you have to add a call in
the onCreate method, and in
onDestroy, and in onResume.
And that allows the Hierarchy
Viewer to connect to your
application and load in the
views just as we've seen.
So let's see how we can use the
Hierarchy Viewer to de-bug
one very common problem that
you often have in your
application.
And it's called overdraw.
And overdraw means that you're
drawing the same pixel
multiple times on the screen.
And obviously that's really
bad for performance,
especially if you define a
background multiple times and
it's always the same color.
It doesn't make much sense
to draw it multiple
times on the screen.
So if you go to the Developer
Options on your device,
there's an option called
Show GPU Overdraw.
And that gives you a nice vision
indication of which
pixels you're drawing
multiple times.
Red and green means you're
drawing it once or twice.
And then light red and red means
you're drawing it more
than three, four, five, times.
That's obviously really bad
for your application.
And if you look here at our app,
you can see that we have
the background of each of the
ListView items is drawn
multiple times.
And then we also have a weird
rectangle behind our
main body of text.
And if you remember,
our application
was completely white.
We're not using any background
colors or anything else
whatsoever.
There's clearly something
going on that we
can optimize here.
So let's have a look at the
Hierarchy Viewer and see how
we can use it to figure out what
exactly is going on here.
So here's our Hierarchy
Viewer.
Here's our linear layout that
defines the right-hand side of
the application, the
details fragment.
And you can see here that we
have a white background behind
the main body of text.
So that's a problem.
Because we all ready have a main
background defined in the
application.
So this is something we should
investigate a bit further.
If you click on the article
body down here, you can
clearly see there's a white
background behind it.
So that's one way you can see
what's being drawn on screen.
Another really useful feature
is the option to export your
entire view layers
as a PSD file.
So that's this option up here.
And if you click that, you can
save all window layers as a
Photoshop file.
And I've already
done this here.
If you open up Photoshop, this
is what it looks like.
And each of the layers in your
view that's visible on the
screen is also visible in
your Photoshop file.
So down here, we have
the DecorVew.
And that's the main
window background.
So if you turn it off, you
can see that there's
still a lot of white.
But the window background
already was white.
That's a bit strange.
And here, we have a linear
layout that has a white
background.
That's again a bit strange.
We have another linear layout.
See, this is coming from each
of our ListView items.
And again, there's the
background right here.
So this is one way that you can
use Hierarchy Viewer to
see how your views are
drawn on the screen.
Another really useful feature
I would like to
show you is this here.
So we have our preview here
that shows you what this
particular view actually
draws to the screen.
And if you double click on this,
you get a bigger view.
But you can also change the
background color of the view.
In this case, because we have
defined white as our
background color for this
layout, this linear layout,
you won't see any changes.
But this can also help you to
see what's transparent and
what's not transparent
in your application.
So let's fix this.
We don't need to define the
background multiple times.
So if you look at our code--
let's go to Android studio--
and the first thing you want
to fix up is the main
background.
So we had our two panes.
And if you remember, there was
a linear layout of all the
backgrounds.
So let's get rid of
that one first.
So that's coming from the
activity two pane XML.
And up here you can see
straightaway we are defining a
background color.
You don't need that.
You can get rid of that.
The next thing, we had a
background color in our
article detail view.
You know how you have the body
of text at the bottom?
So let's get rid of
it here as well.
Color, white--
let's remove that.
And then lastly, we also had
a background color for each
ListView item, in the list of
bacon on the left-hand side.
And our background is actually
select drawable.
And you can see here, we have
different states, depending on
if the particular
item is active.
This is how we are indicating
which article you are looking
at in the application.
And down here, this drawable
down here is the one that's
used by default when it's
in a neutral state.
And again, it's white.
But we can just make
that transparent.
And there's actually a
transparent color that you can
use, you can just-- from
the framework.
So we can just make
that transparent.
And if you run our application
again, you will see that we
have much, much less overdraw.
So if you go back to our
device-- let's just wait for
it to compile.
And here it is.
The green rectangle
we had behind our
caption text is gone.
This is looking much,
much cleaner.
There's no red.
There's only a few blue spots
where we have text that we
actually need to draw
[INAUDIBLE] the screen.
So it's much, much better.
So you've seen how you can use
the overdraw setting to
develop options and the
Hierarchy Viewer to
investigate overdraw issues
in your application.
So I suggest you just enable the
setting and open up your
own application to see how you
can optimize it further.